I got a phone call from my post office early this morning
that our babies had arrived.
With my ADHD brain I totally forgot that I even ordered chicks.
But I always have stuff on hand ready to go.
I need to run to town and get some wood chips to put in the bottom.
Or I might use pine pellets this time.
We'll see. I ordered Cornish cross this time from Hoover Hatchery.
Normally we get Freedom Rangers
and they can pretty much survive just on pasture
once they're out of the brooder,
which I love, so it doesn't cost us that much money to raise them.
But we're in the winter period
so I decided to go with Cornish cross.
I'm gonna feed them and they're gonna be expensive to feed.
That's why I only got I think 20 or 30.
I honestly can't remember what I ordered.
Have to look on the email and open the box.
I was like oh my gosh,
none of them died in the shipping,
which is pretty cool. Normally we lose one or two,
but then I realise one of them did die,
but these are just like savage dinosaurs
and they decided to eat their little friend.
So their little friend didn't die for nothing.
It nourished these chicks on their little trip from Pennsylvania.
I believe. I set their brood up in the shed.
Normally I use the trailer cause we normally brood hundreds at a time,
but I Decided to just do a small amount this time over the winter.
I'm gonna head over to the barn to check on everybody else.
Here is Miss Daisy.
I haven't been in the chicken coop since the day before yesterday,
so we probably have quite a few eggs waiting for me.
Went for this really weird period of having hardly any eggs all summer.
Hi, Miss Rex.
So I have one of those, like,
portable building, really cute chicken cubes
that I bought from one of those side of the road places.
And with the amount of chickens that we have,
it's just not really useful.
So I end up getting rid of that.
And I just converted part of the barn into this cute
little chicken coop area. Now,
this is a Freedom Ranger. She was supposed to be in the freezer,
but they started laying eggs,
and I just couldn't. So I left three,
three or four of these Freedom Ranger hands.
And they lay a lot of eggs.
And she's huge, but she lays really big,
nice eggs. Now,
this black cobble Moran was giving me the side eye.
I just knew she was gonna peck me.
She didn't want me to take her eggs.
I think, though,
she's gone broody. But we'll see.
We'll see if she's around the coop tomorrow.
Now, these are the Turkey hands that are kinda lonely
since Mister Tom ended up in the freezer.
But lessons Learned. They definitely wanna get Bread.
Maybe there'll be a wild Turkey around that will, um,
get the job done.
The geese are lovin the fresh stock tank water I just filled up.
So, you know,
you can't be too long with the fresh,
clean water. They need to get,
jump straight in and shit in there.
So put the eggs inside and pop them in my new Mason Cash bowl,
because I have so many eggs that I have nowhere to put them right now.